[Music]
all right so here are a few warm-ups
that you can do anywhere
especially if you have a little keyboard
all you need is three octaves
[Music]
we're first going to start off with a
basic major triad
now using the thumb to spot we're going
to go up a tritone and play a pair of
chords that has a 1 2 5 grip
a semi tone apart
[Music]
now going back down a tritone we're
going to play a pair of major triads a
semitone apart
[Music]
the first two chords will be broken
upwards
and the next two will be broken
downwards
[Music]
[Music]
the next one is based off of ascending
augmented triads spaced a whole tone
apart
so what's awkward about this one is that
the thumb and index finger on their own
go up a chromatic scale
[Music]
so it'll be good to get used to how that
feels
as we're playing the augmented triads
broken upwards we're connecting one to
the next with the chromatic scale on the
bottom
[Music]
of course we can try this in reverse
with the left hand
[Music]
the next one can be most efficiently
described using a score so i will supply
that here
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
and of course i would transpose this in
a few different keys
[Music]
[Music]
let me know if you want to see more of
these because i have a ton of patterns
and exercises like these that i just
come up with on the road to keep my
fingers moving
and also if you haven't checked out
these other videos that i have on
warm-up exercises on a full-size
keyboard definitely go check them out
[Music]
[Music]